[APPLAUSE]
NATASHA ROSS: Thank you
guys all for coming.
I'm super excited.
Carla is a good friend and
she's in my head a lot,
which is probably
a little dangerous.
But she was here last year.
She had her first book.
This is her second book.
I haven't read it yet.
I know it's going to be amazing.
One of my experiences that
I can share-- my daughter
just turned two.
And on her second
birthday, literally, she
woke up from her nap and
screamed for 15 minutes.
I timed it.
No reason.
She woke up crying.
She-- whatever was going on.
The first thing that
popped into my head
was Carla's voice
from the first book,
telling me that I needed
to react in a way that's
going to help her.
And it was a total
mindfulness thing
where I just sat there
and held her, and was
calm, and as
peaceful as possible,
and waited for it to all pass.
And we keep doing that as she
wakes up from naps screaming.
But the thing that I find
is that she walks away
from that in a much
calmer state than had I
gotten super upset,
super worried,
reacted with her reaction.
So that's Carla in my head.
She has this awesome new book.
It's called "Ready,
Set, Breathe."
And it's practicing
mindfulness with your children
for fewer meltdowns and
a more peaceful family.
And I'm so excited to read it.
So without further ado, Carla.
[APPLAUSE]
CARLA NAUMBURG: Is
the mic turned on?
Fabulous.
Thank you all so much
for coming today.
This is, as Tash mentioned,
my second time speaking here
at Google.
And I had a fabulous
time last year.
So I'm thrilled to be back.
And I want to say
thank you especially
to Tash Ross, who
helped set this all up.
And she's been super
supportive and great.
So what we're going
to do today is
I'm going to do some
reading from the book
so you can get a sense
of what the book is like.
I'm going to do a little bit
of talking about the book,
about mindfulness with our kids.
And then we'll have some time
for questions and answers.
So I hope that sounds good.
All right.
We're going to dive right
in at the very beginning,
the introduction.
"Will you please just calm
down and take a breath,
I snapped at my five-year-old
daughter the other morning.
We had both gotten up on
the wrong side of the bed.
And things had gone
downhill from there.
She was circling
me in the kitchen,
whining and crying
because we had run out
of her favorite cereal.
And I had denied her request
to take a tiny and very
beloved toy to preschool.
Her four-year-old
sister, who was supposed
to be sitting at the table
eating her breakfast,
kept getting down to
grab a toy or finish
a drawing she was working on.
And I had to keep reminding
her to get back in her seat
and finish eating.
Meanwhile, I was
stressed about everything
I needed to do that
morning-- make lunches,
get dressed, finish
packing my work bags,
and hustle everyone
out the door on time.
In the back of my
mind I was feeling
guilty about leaving that
afternoon for a three-day work
trip.
Even though I knew the
girls would be fine at home
with their dad, who's
sitting right over there.
Hi, Josh.
I also knew that my
impending absence
was part of why my daughter
was having such a hard morning.
And I couldn't help
but feel bad about it.
Not unlike my little girl,
I was tired and overwhelmed.
And barking at her to
breathe was the closest
I could get to my
mindfulness practice
in that moment, which is to
say, not very close at all.
Not surprisingly, she
responded in kind.
I don't want to breathe, Mommy.
The ridiculousness
of her statement
may have been lost on her.
But it snapped me out of my own
irritability just long enough
to give me a little perspective.
I put down the
peanut butter knife,
put my hands flat
on the counter,
and took a few deep breaths.
When I felt myself
calm down a little bit,
I picked up my daughter,
sat her down on my lap,
and kept breathing.
Eventually, her heaving
chest calmed down
and her breathing became
more slow and steady.
After a few minutes, she
asked me what I was doing.
I'm just breathing.
That's all.
Oh, she replied with a smile.
Me too.
And so we sat for a few minutes
and just breathed together.
While I know that she
actually was breathing,
I don't know if she
was aware of her breath
in the same way I was.
I had been purposely
paying attention
to the air moving in
and out of my nose.
And each time a
stressful thought
entered my mind about
everything I had to get done,
or how I was going to get
her sister to breakfast,
I let the thought go and
came back to my breath.
For all I know,
my daughter could
have been thinking about baby
dolls, or unicorns, or ice
cream sandwiches, or
anything but her breathing.
The truth is, it
doesn't really matter.
By the time I went
back into the kitchen,
we were both feeling a lot
calmer, more connected,
and present with each
other and ourselves.
It's not that anything
had really changed.
My daughter still wasn't
getting her favorite breakfast
or bringing her toy to school.
And I still had a
million things to do.
The difference was that
once we had calmed down,
rather than freaking
out in our own minds
or subsequently all
over each other,
we were both able to deal
with these challenges
a little more effectively.
The moment that set our
morning on a better path
was the moment when I put
down the knife--" oh, yeah.
Put down the knife.
Mindful parenting pro
tip-- put down the knife.
"--and took a few deep breaths.
When I did that, I
was intentionally
trying to get myself into a
more mindful mindset, which
is simply about paying attention
to whatever is happening right
here and right now without
judging it or wishing
it was different.
I had spent most of the morning
doing one thing with my body--
showering, getting dressed,
or making breakfast--
and another thing with my mind--
generally stressing, worrying,
and feeling guilty.
This split attention
characterizes the way
most of us move through our
daily lives most of the time,
often without even noticing it.
Multi-tasking often fills a
void unavoidable in modern life.
And it can at times help
us be a bit more efficient.
More often than not
however, it leads
to increased stress,
mistakes, and errors,
and snappy responses
to our children.
When I was in the kitchen
making sandwiches,
I was so wrapped up in
my own unhelpful thoughts
that I wasn't really
paying attention
to what was going on
with my daughter, which
is how we got caught up in
a power struggle over toys
and cereal.
But after taking the time
to notice what was really
happening, I was
able to respond to it
in a much more skillful
and effective way
by giving my daughter
the attention she'd
been asking for all along.
The deep breaths I took
were an important step
in helping me get out of my own
head and back into the present.
And that's what
mindful parenting
is all about-- making
a choice to focus
our attention on the
present moment with kindness
and curiosity, so we can make
a thoughtful choice about how
to proceed rather than
reacting out of frustration."
So I chose this passage from
the book for a few reasons.
Number one, as you
noticed, that moment
of mindfulness with my
daughter started with me.
Right?
I was in a pretty not
helpful headspace.
And I kind of had to turn it
around so that I could then
be present with my daughter.
And in the process, I was
teaching her something.
The second important
point from that
is that mindful parents are
not mindful all the time.
There is this
assumption when somebody
says, I practice mindful
parenting, especially
if they say it in an
obnoxious voice like that,
that it sounds like you
assume they sort of walked
through their parenting life
blissed out and zenned out
and totally present and
calm no matter what happens.
And I've never met
anyone like that.
And I'm certainly not like
that. and what mindful parenting
means, or practicing
mindfulness means,
is that we have a set
of skills and tools
and a specific insight
about our own experience
that we can use when
we get off track.
And I get off track
many times a day.
And all it means is
that when I can finally
notice that my mind is a
million miles away, that I'm not
paying attention, that I'm
wrapped up in my own thoughts
and worries, I now
have this understanding
that I don't have to take
the bait of my own brain,
as it were.
I can make a choice to come
back to the present moment.
And often that means
just taking a few breaths
until I can figure out what
I actually need to focus on.
The next reason I
read that passage
is because when we are teaching
mindfulness to our kids,
it works best if we do it with
them, especially initially,
but in an ongoing way.
And I think we all have
this little fantasy
that we can kind of hand our
kid a snow globe or glitter wand
and say, here.
Go look at this and breathe.
And come back when you're calm.
And yes, I wish that too.
But it just doesn't work
that way most of the time.
We need to sit with our kid
and do the practice with them.
And we're both going to benefit.
And eventually they'll
integrate and be
able to do it on their own.
And the last reason
I read that is it's
really important to be
transparent with our kids
about what we're doing.
And so in that
moment, my daughter
said, what are you doing?
And I said, I'm breathing.
And I specifically
said that to her
because I wanted her to know
exactly what I was doing.
I didn't say, I'm
trying to calm down,
because that doesn't help her.
Like, that doesn't
tell her, give her
any information about what
we do to try to calm down.
So I was very concrete.
I'm breathing.
And being transparent about
our own mindfulness practice
is actually harder than
it sounds, because it's
such an internal experience.
It's all about our minds and
how we're perceiving the world
and what we're
choosing to focus on,
and finding a way
to say to your kids,
I'm having a really hard time.
I'm about to lose
it all over you.
I'm going to go in the
other room and breathe.
It's weird.
It's a weird thing
to do, because you
have to have the presence of
mind to notice what's going on.
You have to be able to remember
to tell it to your kids.
And then you have to actually go
do it, which is the hard part,
because we say all these
things we're going to do.
And then we don't do them.
So that's the tricky part.
But I found that
for a long time,
when I was about to lose it
or when I had just lost it,
when I'd yelled at my kids,
I would go in the kitchen
and put my hands on the
counter and start breathing.
And then I'd come back and
I'd be a little calmer.
And my daughters had no idea
what I was doing in there.
For all they knew, I
was sticking my head
in the refrigerator.
So I had to make a point
of starting to say to them,
I'm going in the kitchen to
breathe, so I can calm down.
And now they'll say,
oh, mommy must be upset.
She's going.
She's breathing.
Mommy's breathing.
Yes, I'm breathing.
So those are some
important points.
Now modeling and transparency
are just two of the ways
we can teach mindfulness
to our children.
And I would argue they are two
of the most important ways.
But some other ways
are sharing an activity
with your kid such as
reading a children's book.
There are some really
great ones out there.
My favorite current
picture book,
which is probably good up
through second or third grade,
is called "Charlotte and the
Quiet Place," by Debbie Sosa.
And it's a lovely story
about this little girl named
Charlotte who can't--
she lives in a busy city.
She can't find any quiet.
And she goes out for
a walk with her dog.
The dog runs away.
She chases him.
And then they're
both kind of panting
because they've been running.
And in that she finds her
breath and finds a quiet place.
But you can read a
children's book to your kids.
There are some
great apps for kids.
Just to be clear, screen time
is not mindfulness practice.
Right?
Because even though our
kids look like they're
being calm and focusing,
they're spacing out.
It's not mindfulness.
So that's not to say
screen time is bad.
It's just to say, don't
think your kids are
meditating in front of
"Caillou," because they're not.
And then you can also teach your
kids specific skills and tools
like breathing activities,
noticing activities.
And I'm going to talk
about some of those today.
But before we go on, I
want to take a minute
to define mindfulness,
because this is a word that's
all over the place these days.
And I think many of us have
misconceptions about what it is
and what it isn't.
So the traditional sort
of Western definition
of mindfulness, which
was first put forth
by Jon Kabat-Zinn,
who worked out
at UMass Worcester
for a long time.
And he started mindfulness-based
stress reduction.
His traditional definition
is paying attention
to the present moment
in a nonjudgmental way.
Now I don't know
about you, but those
are pretty big words for kids.
And I personally don't
like it when somebody
tells me to pay attention.
I don't think my kids
respond particularly well.
And furthermore, how
many of you have ever
had someone tell you, or
define for you, or tell you
how to pay attention?
Anybody?
I don't-- OK.
So what did you hear?
What did somebody tell you?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CARLA NAUMBURG: OK.
So for everybody out
there, what he said was,
he was told to focus on
what they were saying
and listen the way they
wanted him to listen.
And it didn't feel very helpful.
I agree.
That doesn't sound very fun.
So the definition I like
for kids, which I also
borrowed components from Amy
Saltzman, who's a physician out
in the Bay Area who also
teaches mindfulness,
is noticing the present moment
with kindness and curiosity
so we can choose
our next behavior.
That choosing the next behavior,
that's like the pot of gold
at the end of the
parenting rainbow.
We all want kids who can
take a moment and say,
I'm actually going to choose
to use my words instead
of dropping to the floor and
screaming like a crazy person.
So that's what we're
going for with our kids
and with ourselves,
is the sense that we
have some choice in
what we're going to do,
instead of just reacting.
So let's break down this
definition a little bit.
So the first part is noticing.
Kids know how to notice.
Right?
My daughter can notice a baby
doll from like a mile away.
She's got an insane
radar for it.
Little boys often can
notice trucks and tractors.
And I know, gender split.
Blah, blah, blah.
But what I've seen, this is
like how it seems to break down.
So noticing is super important
because so much happens
in our life that we
just don't even see it.
I mean, we can walk
through our-- I mean,
I've driven the same
way to school every day.
And I had no idea that the
giant Santa was up on the corner
until my daughter's like, look!
There's Santa there.
And I think he'd been
there for a week.
This thing is like 10 feet tall.
It's enormous.
I was so wrapped up in
my own mind, I missed it.
Right?
So, so much of our life
happens without noticing it.
And if we aren't noticing, if
we aren't paying attention,
to use that phrase, it
will go right past us.
And so how do we notice things?
Well, we can notice
them with our eyes.
We can notice them
with our ears.
I mean, all of our senses.
When we touch something.
When we taste it.
When we smell it.
But the art of noticing is
about-- or paying attention--
is about choosing to bring
our attention, whatever
part of our body
we're doing that with,
and focus it on something.
Right?
To notice it to pay
attention to it.
And then when our mind
wanders, we bring it back.
And that's the part that I think
we lose in this definition is
that everybody assumes that
when you're paying attention,
you are paying 100% attention,
and your mind never strays.
Well, I don't know how many
of your minds can do that.
But mine certainly can't.
And so the trick to noticing
and paying attention
is to be OK when your mind
wanders, and then say, oh.
My mind just wandered.
I'm going to bring it back to
what we we're talking about.
So that's the first part.
The next part is
the present moment.
Now the vast majority of
us spend the vast majority
of our time in the
past or in the future.
We're worried about something
that may or may not happen.
We're planning for events.
We're sort of fantasizing about
how a conversation may go.
Or we're in the past kind
of regretting, wishing
things had been different, or
feeling nostalgic for something
that's already gone.
This is a very useful
skill to have, in fact.
You know, the caveman,
whenever, millions
of years ago who could
remember that when
Uncle Joe went into
that cave and got eaten
by a saber-tooth tiger, and can
plan in the future to not get
eaten by that saber
tooth tiger, is
the one who's more
likely to have kids
and you know, pass
along his genes.
So this brain that can do
this is a very useful thing.
And you know, now
as parents, when
we can remember the anaphylactic
shock that our kid had
when she ate a peanut,
and make a plan to send
a peanut-free cupcake to the
birthday party, not only are
we had avoiding an allergic
reaction, but potentially
a major meltdown.
So this is a good thing.
The problem is, our brains
don't know when to turn it off.
Right?
We're constantly doing it.
And there's a couple
problems with this.
One is we can't get accurate
data on what's actually
happening if we're
not paying attention
to what's actually happening.
If we're too busy filtering
the world around us
through a lens of what's going
to happen next, or oh, gosh.
This is reminding me
of this thing that
happened all these years ago.
And now I'm sort of
thinking about that.
And I'm not really seeing.
And parenting, man.
That gets us going.
Right?
Because no matter what's
going on with our kids,
we're always sort of
balancing between what's
going to happen next and
what already happened.
So my daughter, when she was
having a hard time learning
to ride a bike, I
was automatically
like, she's going to be 40
and she can't ride a bike.
And her husband's going to want
to take her on this bike trip
to France.
And she's not going
to be able to go.
And all her friends
are going to go.
And it's going to be
like this awkward thing.
And it's going to cause
them marital-- what?
That's insane.
But that's where my brain went.
And then, of course, I was
worried about the past.
Like oh, man.
Last summer we didn't
work on the bike riding.
And it's my fault.
If I had worked
on the bike riding
last summer, we
would totally be all over this.
And she'd be with
all these other kids,
riding their bike like a little
gang of Hello Kitty sparkled
gangsters, or something.
But what I needed was to be with
her right there in that moment,
holding the handlebar
and walking with her.
That's where we can make
a difference, right?
The present is
where the action is.
So it's where we can get the
best information on what's
actually happening.
And it's where we can
actually take action.
That's why the present
moment is so important.
Let's talk about this
kindness and curiosity bit.
This is also the
non-judgmental thing.
So for most of us,
when we actually
come to the present moment,
we immediately judge it.
Sometimes we judge
it as pretty good.
And then we whip out
our phones and want
to take a picture of it,
which immediately takes us out
of the present moment,
because then you're like,
oh, I got a Facebook message.
I better check that one.
And all of a sudden you're like
buried with some other person
a million miles
away on Facebook.
Or we judge it as
kind of boring.
We don't like boring.
Human beings are
terrible at boring.
So we really want
that to be different.
Or it's great.
And then we're like,
oh, it's going to end.
This is awful.
Or it's terrible.
And then all we
can think about is
how soon we can get out of it.
Most of us, most of
the time, are not
walking around going, huh.
Things are pretty OK right now.
I'm right with this.
Or most the time
we're not curious.
Like, what's going on?
So if we're in like a
terrible traffic situation,
it's like, oh.
This is miserable.
I'm never going to
get to work on time.
As opposed to, huh.
Why is all this traffic here?
Which sounds like a really
ridiculous question.
But it gets you out
of this crazy mind.
So when we can be in the
present moment with this kind,
curious stance,
not only is it sort
of a much more
pleasant way to be,
but we're more likely to
take more effective action.
So there's this whole
field of study now called
self-compassion.
How many of you like have
that word come into your lives
on a daily basis?
Even a regular basis?
Well, my husband.
But.
Yeah.
OK.
So what researchers
have found is
that when you take a
compassionate response
to anything that's happening
in your life, especially
difficult things, your
next action is much more
likely to be more effective.
So let me give you an example
that most women, many men
can relate to.
You decide you're
going to go on a diet.
And two days later you find
yourself eating an Oreo.
Now what most people think
after they eat the Oreo?
I suck.
I'm miserable at this.
Everybody else can diet.
And I can't.
This is so hard.
It's never going to happen.
Forget it.
And then what happens?
You eat the whole sleeve.
It's gone.
Right?
The Oreos are gone.
But if your response is, huh.
That was interesting.
Why'd I do that?
Dieting is really hard.
Everyone struggles with it.
It's OK.
I made a mistake.
You are much more likely
to put those Oreos away.
And this is true for almost
every behavior change.
So sometimes when we talk
about self-compassion,
it can sound a
little touchy-feely.
It's actually an
incredibly effective way
to approach our own experience
and our kids' experience.
And then the last one is sort
of choosing our next behavior.
So we've got noticing
the present moment
with kindness and
curiosity so we
can choose our next behavior.
This whole noticing the
present moment, kindness,
and curiosity bit-- that's all
about creating enough space
in our awareness so we can
figure out what's actually
going on, and then make the
best and most skillful choice
about what to do next.
Because most of the time
it's like, something happens.
We get this input.
And then we immediately react.
Boom.
And that reaction, it could
be from a place of worry.
It could be from a
place of anxiety.
It could be from a place
of remembering something
that happened two
weeks or 20 years ago.
And we don't even know
that we're remembering it.
Right?
Our brains work that
amazingly that all of a sudden
we're triggered.
Our kid spills the milk,
the Cheerios, right?
And we're flipping
out at our kid.
Not because we actually
care about the spilled milk
or Cheerios, but because
when we were kids,
we got yelled at for
spilling milk and Cheerios.
And it triggers that
automatic reaction.
So we can slow
down and say, huh.
That's interesting.
Sounds really cheesy
when I say it.
But when you do it enough
times in your brain,
you get used to it.
Then we can say, OK.
My kid spilled the
milk and Cheerios.
What is the most effective
way to respond to this?
And then you figure it out.
So does that all
make sense right now?
All right.
So if we start with this
mindfulness definition,
let's take a minute
to talk about why
do we actually want this
for our kids and ourselves?
Like, we parents have enough
on our plate to figure out.
Right?
Why interject this new
practice, this new idea?
Well, there has been
a shocking amount
of research on this
with kids, primarily
in schools and
clinics where they're
teaching it to children.
And what they
found is everything
we want for our child-- right?
Growing awareness of their
bodies, their thoughts,
and their emotions, and
an increased ability
to verbalize it.
And how great would it be
if every time our kids were
having a hard time, they came
to us and said, gee, Mom.
I'm having a hard time today.
I think my stomach hurts.
Can you please help me
find a solution to this?
As opposed to like, melting
down and flipping out
in the car on the way to school.
Right?
So kids do that.
Increased resilience and
ability to soothe themselves,
to calm down, and to
regulate their emotions.
This is something most of us
grownups are still working on.
If we can start to help our
kids do it, that's amazing.
Increased empathy.
A stronger sense of
other people's emotions.
Improved concentration
and ability to focus.
Better sleep.
That's a good one, right?
Increased confidence.
Decreased anxiety.
Like, all of these things.
And it sounds like this
panacea, like this magic potion.
And it's not.
But if you think of all of
these things, so many of them
happen, so many of the
challenges we face-- not being
able to concentrate,
struggling with big feelings,
not knowing how to manage
them, not sleeping well
at night, so many of those
come from this awareness
and this attention that's
all over the place.
It's like that pinball machine
you guys have right here.
The thoughts are like
constantly bouncing around.
And that makes it hard
to do the things we want
and need to do in life.
So the good news is that
our children are already
little zen masters.
Now there's two ways
to think about this.
One, the role of a zen
master is to constantly push
your buttons.
So you have lots
of opportunities
to practice mindfulness.
And I'm sure that's the one many
of you can relate to, right?
But I would argue
that children are also
capable of great mindfulness,
of moments of intense awareness,
concentration, and presence.
The problem is they
always want to do it
when we need them to
put on their shoes
and get out the door.
Having said that,
I would to read
you a section from the book
about sort of encouraging
these mindful
moments in our kids,
how we can sort of
recognize and support
when our kids are already
being mindful inherently.
"I'm sure you've witnessed your
child having a mindful moment.
Perhaps it's when he is intent
on building the tallest LEGO
tower ever, or spinning
an elaborate fairy
tale about fairies living
in the bedside table,
or is focused on
hearing every word
and note of a favorite song.
Maybe it's when he's in
the zone on the soccer
field, about to score a goal.
While none of these may seem
like particularly mindful
moments, they are.
When your child is focused
on just one thing, when
he's fully engaged, not judging
himself or wishing something
were different, he is
practicing mindfulness,
even though he's not sitting
cross-legged on the floor
with his eyes closed.
When your child is
expressing interest
in the world around him
by mushing his banana
between his fingers to
see what it feels like,
or by stopping to
notice a flower growing
through a crack in the
pavement, or by asking
questions about what
happens when we die,
why we have to eat vegetables,
or the shape of the human body,
he is being mindfully curious
about the world around him.
And finally, when your child
is being aware of and concerned
about someone else's feelings
or health or well-being, when
he brings a special toy
to a crying sibling,
or makes a card for
a friend's birthday,
or visits a sick
friend after school,
he's practicing
mindful compassion.
These moments are important
for several reasons.
Each time our children are
concentrating, being curious,
or creative, or
demonstrating compassion--"
See what I did there?
Concentrating, curious,
creative compassion.
All the Cs?
Help you remember,
"They are learning
to pay attention and
notice what is happening
within them and around them.
They are learning to make
connections, think in new ways,
and respond skillfully to
difficult, challenging,
or boring situations.
They are practicing
empathy and kindness
towards themselves or others.
And they are drawing on
their own inner experience
for inspiration,
guidance, and soothing,
rather than counting on
someone else to do it for them.
The more often they do all of
these things, the more likely
they will be able to
do them in the future,
because even the seemingly
small behaviors are developing
and strengthening
habits and skills
and the neural connections
in the relevant parts
of their brains.
These are just a few
of the reasons why
it's important to practice
mindfulness with our children
when they're calm,
happy, and doing well.
The other reason is that those
are the times when they're
most likely to be
receptive to what
we're trying to teach them.
The more they
practice these skills
when they are in a good
space, the more likely
they'll be able to
access and utilize them
in difficult moments.
As one of my mindfulness
teachers once put it,
you can't practice
crisis meditation.
As our children get better
practicing mindfulness
in the calm, uneventful moments
of daily life, the more likely
they'll be able to
access this skill
when we really
want them to, when
they're overcome with
anger, anxiety, or sadness.
Actively teaching your children
about the ideas and practices
of mindfulness is part of
the process, to be sure,
and will be covered
more in later chapters.
However, you'll be most
successful in your endeavors
if you can notice when
your child is already
being his own little zen
master, and support him
in that process, or at the very
least, not get in the way."
So two important points here.
One is that we need
to find and create
those times in their lives
when our kids can be mindful,
and we can stay
out of their way.
Because so often we're nudging
and nagging and let's go,
let's go, and we've got
to do this next thing,
and you've got to
clean up your room,
and it's time to
do your homework,
and we've got to
get ready for dinner
that we don't give
them that space.
And so I was guilty of that too.
This year we had our kids in
swimming, guitar, and dance.
And they're in kindergarten
and first grade.
And somehow when I set this
all up, it seemed reasonable.
And now that I say it, it
seems totally ridiculous.
But what I realized is
that they had no free time.
And they needed time to
just sit and be and play.
And I was seeing it
in their behavior.
They were getting
grumpy and irritable.
And basically we'd spend all
day Saturday managing tantrums,
because they were
exhausted after the week.
So swimming and guitar out.
They're doing dance
on Sunday mornings
because we need
someplace to take them
in the winter on the weekends.
And that's it.
And we come home from school.
And I'm like, go play.
I'm making dinner.
And sometimes they need a
little help getting into it.
But once they're into
it, it's their space
to kind of be
present and creative.
And they really need that.
And this is a big challenge
for us parents, parenting
in this cohort in this
culture, because it's
like we have to prepare
our kids for everything.
They have to be able
to play an instrument
and speak a language, or they
will never work at Google.
And the thing about
that is they also
need the emotional skills
to deal with boredom
and frustration, because we can
send them to every math camp,
but if they get frustrated
when they get one problem wrong
and they give up on
the test, it doesn't
matter how much they know.
And especially the younger ages.
But at all ages we need to
create the space for our kids.
The next thing I would
say that's super important
is the reason that many
of us come to mindfulness
for ourselves and
for our children is
to deal with our own personal
challenges and our children's
challenges.
Like, dear God.
I want this child to stop
melting down in Pan Ear.
I can't deal with this.
And so then what we do is
we bust out our little trick
when they're having a hard time.
That doesn't work.
That's like you trying to
teach me to code computer
languages when I'm like
really sad about something
or really angry.
It's not going to happen.
Like, we can't integrate
new information
when we're in a bad space
emotionally, especially
little ones, but all of us.
Their brains are just
flooded with hormones
when they're melting down.
They can't even hear the words
coming out of your mouth,
much less learn
something new from you.
So we have to find ways
to start integrating this
into our daily lives when
they're calm and happy
and feeling connected.
And if we do that often
enough, then they'll
have it available when
they really need it.
So the other day my
5 and 1/2 year old
was sitting on the
couch like this.
[PANTING]
And I was like, Rose,
what are you doing?
And she's like, I'm
very upset, Mommy.
I'm breathing!
And like, this is
not the breathing
that I think is really
going to help her calm down.
But for months now
we've been practicing
breathing, and doing breathing.
And finally she was
like trying to breathe
in the middle of a meltdown.
And I was like, that is
a huge win right there,
even though she was
actually hyperventilating.
But we'll get there.
So starting it when your
kids are in a good space,
and working on this.
And as you'll
notice in the book,
it doesn't have to
be a huge thing.
It's not like we're going
to pull out the meditation
cushions and light the incense
and bang the singing bowl
and sit down and breathe.
Like, if that's your
style, that's fantastic.
But if it's like, hey, let's
sit down and play Legos.
And I'm going to
work really hard not
to nag you about how
to make that tower
the most stable tower ever.
And I'm just going
to let you be.
Or if it's like,
my daughters and I
will sit on the front porch.
And I'll say, let's
just listen for sounds.
I'll give you one minute.
And I want you to report
back to me two sounds.
And the minute is
actually like 25 seconds,
because that's what they
can handle right now.
But they get quiet.
And they listen for two sounds.
And then I'll say,
let's just sit together
and breathe for 10 seconds.
Can we notice our breathing?
My seven-year-old can
definitely do 10 seconds.
My five-year-old is
like, four seconds.
My brain is like two seconds.
But you know,
practicing these things
and finding ways to work
them into your daily life.
If you have a religious
or spiritual practice,
you can say your prayers
together and recognize
that as a mindfulness practice.
And many of these things
when you read the book,
you'll be like, oh.
I'm already doing that.
We play Jenga.
I didn't know that was
a mindfulness practice.
The trick is deciding it is.
So making a point
to pay attention,
and then notice when your
attention has wandered.
And then bring it back.
And so all of these
things, when we really
make a point to insert
them into our day,
are going to end up
being quite useful.
So I want to give you a
couple of tricks and tips
before I leave.
My favorite mindfulness
trick is that you
can't be curious and
angry at the same time.
This is extremely cool.
And I never noticed it until
someone told me recently.
But curiosity comes from
our prefrontal cortex,
which is right up here.
And it requires that
this part of our brain
that can plan and think and
process and manage emotions,
that this part is online.
And anger comes from
back here, right?
This is like the reptilian
fight, flight, freak out,
freeze part of our brain that's
like, I can't even think.
And even though you just offered
me a snack and ice cream,
I'm still screaming at you,
because I'm losing my mind.
So those can't function
at the same time.
They just can't.
So when this part's
turned on, our kids
can't think or do anything.
But if we can get this
part to come online,
the back calms
down a little bit.
So one of the tricks
I'll do with my daughter
when she's really losing it--
and I have to wait until she's
calm enough to at
least hear my voice--
is I'll try to get her curious
about the world around us.
So if we were in this room
together and she was losing it,
I would say, hey.
Can you find a
screen in this room?
Like, make it really
easy to start.
So I'm not going to say,
can you find somebody
who's wearing brown boots?
That's too much.
And then, can you
find me like, a chair?
And sometimes if
she's so lost, like,
she couldn't find a
chair in this room.
But make it really easy and see
if you can get them curious.
Now my older daughter
will say to me,
don't do that trick on me!
I don't want that trick!
I want to be angry!
And I'm like, OK.
Then you let her be angry.
And your job in that
moment is to stay calm
so she can get
through the anger.
So that's a nifty trick also in
life when you're getting like,
pissed off.
Like when I'm pissed
off in traffic,
I try to get curious
about tail lights.
Tail lights come in a lot of
different shapes and sizes.
It's amazing.
I had no idea.
And I'm like, hm,
there's a round one.
So can you get curious
about something?
It really helps you calm down.
And then I want to read you
a little bit about something
called a cool down corner,
which is a very helpful space
to set up for a kid.
And I also thought it'd
be appropriate for Google,
because you guys have
a million of them here.
And they're shaped like
airplanes and jails
and really cool--
well, not jails.
That's not the best example.
But.
So creating a calm down corner.
In addition to making a
more mindful environment
throughout your house, which
is something I talk about
in the book, you may
want to consider creating
a special calm down corner.
This can be a
small room, or even
a corner of a room, a
small comfortable chair,
or an indoor child's tent.
The idea is to
create a space that
is conducive to a calm,
mindful experience,
and that specifically cues your
child to get quiet and focused.
It's a good idea to involve
your child as much as
possible in the
design of the space
and in choosing
what to put in it.
You'll want it to be
decorated in a way that
appeals to him or her,
keeps her interested,
and helps her get and stay calm.
Here are a few ideas
to keep in mind.
You can choose a calming
theme for the space.
But you don't have to.
I have one friend who named her
kid space the cool down corner,
and filled it with
books about Antarctica,
as well as a few stuffed
polar bears and penguins.
Another friend created
a seat in space.
She and her son cut out
some stars and planets
to hang from the
sky, and included
a favorite stuffed
alien doll, and
a few different
space-themed toys and books.
Choose a few toys that your
child would like to have,
or activities she can do
completely unsupervised.
So like if Play-Doh
freaks you out,
don't put the Play-Doh in there.
Like, put stuff that you can
leave the kid alone with.
You'll want to work with her
to choose things that are age
or developmentally appropriate.
Don't put too much stuff
in the calm down corner.
Regardless of how cluttered
the rest of your house may be,
this is an area that you
have just a few items.
Too much stuff will make
it hard for your child
to focus and choose what to do.
You'll want to include
items and toys that
are known and comforting
to your little one,
not items to
challenge her to try
new or different activities.
No need to spend much money.
You likely already
have or can make
anything you want to include.
No screens, tablets,
or electronic toys
in the calm down corner, with
the exception of an MP3 or CD
player loaded with
guided meditations.
And you can get them on
like eBay really cheap that
don't have a screen on them.
Like the old school iPod ones.
This is not a time-out spot.
And your child should
not be forced into it.
It may be a spot she chooses
instead of time-outs if you
use time-outs in your house.
But it should always be a
place she goes willingly.
You want your child to
have positive associations
with the calm down corner,
which won't feel easy if it
feels like a jail cell to her.
The calm down corner
is a sacred space
where shouting, nagging,
arguing, discussing,
questioning, and
negotiating are not allowed.
This space isn't
for figuring things
out or rehashing problems.
It's just for being,
breathing, and doing
quiet, soothing activities.
That's all.
Once you're there, you're safe.
And that last bit is
the hardest part for me,
because I want to
go after my kid.
Be like, wait.
We're not done
talking about this!
Not the time to do that.
If you don't have the space
in your house to do that,
you can also create like a calm
down box or a little cloth bag.
And you can put-- my kids
love Silly Putty is always
a good choice.
And it doesn't-- I mean, it can
sort of get mashed into a rug,
but not as bad as Play-Doh.
Like they sell
little glitter ones
that are nice things to look at.
A small notepad and some pens.
If your kid is
into Rubik's cubes
and that's not going to stress
her out, something like that.
Anything they can sort of
manipulate with their bodies
is really useful.
I mean, some kids really
like strong scents.
So you can find a little
scented pillow to put in there.
Whatever works for your kid.
And you really have to pay
attention to your child,
because everybody's got
different things that work.
And then the last
trick I really have
is get your kids outside
as much as possible.
And I know we all hear this.
And when somebody tells me that,
and I'm in a stressed moment,
I'm like, I can't even deal.
And have you met Boston winter?
Like, don't talk to me.
But it makes a huge difference.
There's not as much
clutter around,
and kids can move
their bodies more.
All of this helps us get
into a more mindful space.
And so in the winter we bundle
our kids up and we go outside.
And sometimes we spend 10
minutes getting dressed
and five minutes outside.
And that's OK.
But it's much more easy for
kids to get in a mindful space
when they're outside.
So those are some ideas.
There's a lot more in the book.
And at the risk of sounding
like a TV salesperson,
there are over 100
activities in this book.
And I interviewed 30
different parents for this,
because there are
many, many great books
on the market about teaching
mindfulness to children.
And I can recommend some to
folks who are interested.
Most of them are based on
the author's experiences
in schools and clinics, which
is really useful and important.
But anyone who has ever tried to
teach their own child anything
knows it's really different
from how kids learn at school.
And there's all sorts of
dynamics that happen at home.
And we also have lots
of opportunities at home
that don't happen at school.
But I wanted this book
to be representative
of a lot of different
families' experiences.
Because my family is quirky.
And we have our own
preferences and a certain way
of doing things.
So I talked to 30
different parents
about how they do this at home.
So there's a whole lot of
activities and ideas in here.
And choose the ones that work
for you and make up your own.
And don't worry if some
don't work for you.
It's not your gig.
That's fine.
But that's the book.
That's the talk.
Hopefully we have some
time for questions.
Oh.
Here's somebody.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
one picture book to share
with kids in the course of it.
I wonder if you had any
suggestions for even moving
older, the 10 and
11-year-old who is old enough
to recognize, wow, I
regularly screw things up
when I get really stressed out.
And you know, I say things
that I don't want to say.
So a little older
than picture book,
but maybe not ready to just
take an adult self-help book
off the shelf and
plow through it.
CARLA NAUMBURG:
This is a question
I frequently get at talks.
And I've been looking
for something.
And I haven't found anything
I love for that age.
There is-- and again, I don't
like pushing the screen time
for this particular issue,
because it's not really
what we're going for.
But there's a website.
I could be wrong.
I think it's called GoZen.com.
But if you look up like,
zen anxiety, kids, YouTube,
it will pop up.
And whether or not
anxiety is the issue,
I know that that's one of
the things they address.
And they have some pretty good
animations that are helpful.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks very much.
CARLA NAUMBURG: Yeah.
Please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
CARLA NAUMBURG: Oh, yeah.
So the question was, does it
not work for kids under three?
No.
It definitely works
for kids under three.
I mean, my publisher was
like, pick an age range.
And I was like, OK.
But I mean the reality is
it's all about figuring out
what works for your kids.
Like, under three
you can totally
start doing these
activities with your kids.
The ones that are going
to be most effective
is the ones you practice.
And then it sort of leaks out,
for lack of a better term,
to your children.
So when we can stay calm
when our children wake up
from the nap screaming,
that's a great one.
When we can let our
toddlers and little ones
have the space and the time
to just play and explore
the environment, and we're not
like getting in their space.
And I never thought
this would be
a thing I did until I had kids.
But then, I'm like,
oh, you're playing.
Let's make your play better.
Like, let me get your space
and help you make that better.
And Josh and I
stopped doing this
when we read a quote by
Jack Black, the actor.
He said in "USA Today," "never
give a happy child ice cream."
And I was like, oh.
That's right.
I'll save the ice cream for
when maybe they're not so happy.
Bribe them with ice cream.
No.
But like, if they're doing
well, leave them alone.
And that's surprisingly hard
to do when it's especially me.
I want to get like in it.
And then Josh is
like, ice cream!
And then I can like step away.
So with the little
ones, and also food
is a great time to let them
sort of mindfully be curious,
if you can tolerate it.
Right?
Because then you end up with
food all over the place.
And it's like, I
just gave you a bath
and now you have
hummus in your hair.
But if you can let them really
explore food and kind of sit
with it and mush
it around, that's
a great practice for
little ones, too.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any tips
for parents in the moment?
So when kids are freaking
out, the parents then
are freaking out because of it.
CARLA NAUMBURG: Yes.
Tips for parents who are
freaking out in the moment.
So that's what the
first book is about.
It's called "Parenting
in the Present Moment."
But briefly, yes.
When you are freaking
out, my tips are,
see if you can breathe.
Like, pay attention
to your breath.
And a lot of times people
think breathing meditation
is this like whole big thing.
Like, you have to breathe in for
four and breathe out for seven,
and then stand on your head,
and then like chant a mantra.
It's not.
Just notice your breath,
however it is, wherever it is.
Some people notice
it in their nose.
it in their chest.
Some people notice
it in their belly.
Just notice.
And that will like
calm you down.
Another one is like, for some
people putting their hands
on a counter top.
That works for me kind
of to get grounded.
For some people
just sitting down,
like feeling your body in
contact with something firm
can help you feel grounded.
And then remembering
a few things.
One is, unless your
child is in danger,
you don't have to
react right away, which
can be such a hard thing
when they're screaming.
Like, they can
scream for a minute.
They can tolerate it, especially
if they know that you're around
and they're safe.
And if they ask you
something and you
don't know what to
do, like, you don't
have to have an answer, right?
You can say, I need some
time to think about that.
And the other thing
is that you can always
start a mindfulness practice
again and again and again.
So there's a saying in
the mindfulness world,
which is that it's really
easy to be mindful.
It's really hard to
remember to be mindful.
And so some of us will get to
this place where it's like, ah.
It's the end of the day,
and I forgot to do laundry,
and I forgot to be mindful.
I totally screwed that up.
And then we beat
ourselves up, because we
want to be these calm parents.
And instead we
yelled at our kids.
So that moment when you
notice that you're ramped up,
that you're a
million miles away,
that you're yelling
whatever it is,
that's what Sharon
Salzberg-- who
is a very well-regarded and
one of the leading meditation
teachers in this country--
she calls it the Magic Moment.
Any moment you notice
and become aware,
I am losing it with
my kid, is the moment
you can choose to make
a different choice.
And every once in a while
I have enough awareness
that I will actually stop
yelling at my kids mid-yell.
And it's surprisingly
effective, because they're
expecting this rant.
And then all of a
sudden, you just stop.
And they're like, whoa.
What happened?
And so whenever you can catch
it, you can always stop.
And we also have this
thing with parenting
that we have to be
consistent, right?
So once you've laid
the law down, like,
you cannot change
your mind ever.
It's actually not true.
We make mistakes.
We say the wrong thing.
We set a limit that's
not the right one.
Or we don't set
enough of a limit.
You can go back and say,
actually, I changed my mind.
Right?
But it's important
that we when it can,
it comes from a mindful
place, as opposed to,
I'm going to set this limit.
But now you're being
a jerk about it.
And I don't really
want to fight with you.
I'm tired.
I just want you to go to bed
so I can watch my TV show,
so I'm going to change my mind.
Like, that's not
really so effective.
But when you can say, huh.
Now that I'm calm, I realize
I didn't actually mean that.
That's a better way.
But check out the first book.
"Parenting in the Present
Moment."
It's got some good tips.
And also, last tip.
And then I see there's
another question.
Start practicing this
when you're calm.
Because just like we talked
about with your kids,
you can't teach them a new
skill when they're freaking out.
We can't teach ourselves a new
skill when we're freaking out.
So if we expect ourselves
to be able to start
a mindfulness practice
when our kids are
like really pushing our buttons,
it's not going to happen.
So either try meditation,
which is a great one.
Or if you're like, I am
not sitting on a cushion
right now, that's
not happening, lady,
then the other
thing you can do is
pick one or two activities
you know you do every day,
and pay attention to them.
And when your mind
wanders, as it
will after about two
seconds, come back.
So for me it's taking a shower.
I can get to the
end of my shower.
My hair is wet.
I have no idea if I washed it.
Not a clue.
And so can you pick one or
two things you enjoy doing.
Don't make it harder
than it has to be.
Drinking your coffee.
Reading to your kids.
Whatever it is.
And just pay attention.
So those are things
that will help.
And the more you do that, the
more your brain gets better
at noticing, the more likely
you will be to notice.
Yeah.
Please.
AUDIENCE: This book looks great.
I'm really looking
forward to reading it.
CARLA NAUMBURG: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: One
place that where we
found the good ideas
tend to break down
is when you have multiple kids.
And I'm curious to know whether
the book addresses it or not.
I'm thinking of the
calm down space.
In my house that would turn
into the thunderdome, basically.
One kid we could maybe do that.
But then, especially if there's
just one parent at home,
you got to go make dinner.
And usually we try good ideas.
And then it's either
yelling or TV.
You know, it's like, those
become our two options.
So I'm just curious.
When you're outnumbered,
anything in the book
or otherwise that--
CARLA NAUMBURG: How
many kids do you have?
AUDIENCE: Three so far.
CARLA NAUMBURG: Yes.
So you are well outnumbered.
You know, this is
a huge problem.
So the calm down
space, you're right.
This is a big issue
that comes up.
But you can still do it
with the calm down space,
even with multiple kids.
And like in my daughters'
classrooms-- in every classroom
at my daughter's school
from K through 8,
they have a calm down space.
That's one space
for like 24 kids.
So they have to take turns.
And my daughter will come
home frustrated sometimes
that she didn't get her turn.
That's fine.
So having a space in the
house is a good idea.
But yes.
When all three kids
are melting down,
that's when you have to put down
the knife-- which I'm making
reference to my own experience.
I'm not implying you
carry knives around.
Although--
And go be with them.
And that's a moment.
So one of the words that comes
up a lot in mindfulness world
is acceptance.
I don't love that
word, because it's
like we have to accept and just
be OK that our kids are going
to like, cry forever.
I like the word
acknowledgement better.
You have to just
acknowledge in that moment
that everyone is melting down.
And you have to make
the best choice you can.
And sometimes the
best choice is TV.
Like, practicing
mindfulness does not
mean we do the number one
best parenting intervention
at all times.
And in fact, I would
argue that's not
helpful for your kids,
because then your kids learn
that all of their
needs will be met
in the most effective way
at every moment-- which
guess what-- is not
how the world works.
So sometimes you yell.
Sometimes you turn on the TV.
But when your kids
are old enough
that you can start
to strategize,
like can one of them go to their
rooms if they need a break,
by choice.
Can you use the
calm down corner?
Maybe a kid needs to
plug-in some headphones
and listen to a
guided meditation.
I mean, it really involves
a lot of creativity.
But you can do it with
more than one kid.
You just can't expect to do
it perfectly all the time.
And that's when the
self-compassion and kindness
and curiosity is
really important,
because it's like, oh.
I just lost it.
And so can I be nice to
myself and forgive myself.
Because most of us when we
do an unskilful parenting
intervention, we tend to
beat ourselves up about it.
I'm a terrible parent.
I can't believe I lost it.
Everybody else is
doing it better.
And then we get stuck.
And then our kids
come in the room.
And we bite their
heads off because we're
in a bad head space.
So when you can be like, OK.
Well, that was a rough moment.
Glad that's over.
And thank God for TV, because
it's really useful sometimes.
Then you're much more likely
to have a batterer intervention
next time.
But it's tricky.
Multiple kids is tricky.
You can also do little
group meditation things.
Like I'll get my girls together
and we do practices together.
And again, this comes
back to starting it
when everybody's
in a good space,
because the more you
try to just start it
when they're in a bad space,
you're setting everyone
up for failure.
And then maybe boarding school.
I don't know.
That could help.
Was somebody over here
who had a question?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about siblings arguing.
CARLA NAUMBURG: It was
the sibling arguing.
OK.
So here's the thing
about sibling arguing.
I am not an expert
in sibling arguing.
And I did a lot of
it when I was a kid.
And my girls do it now.
Laura Markham has a
book-- M-A-R-K-H-A-M--
about sibling rivalry that
I've heard good stuff about.
But I think that remembering
that it's normal,
like some amount
of it is normal.
I mean, I saw some statistic
that kids get into it
with their siblings
like once every seven
seconds or something.
Yikes.
But that it's an important
part of their socialization.
Like, that's how they
learn to figure things out.
And what I would say--
and this isn't necessarily
a mindfulness bit-- is
depending on how old they are
and if everybody's safe, can
you just get out of the way
and encourage them
to figure it out.
And one of my friends, what
she'll do is she'll say,
either you guys figure it
out, or I take away the toy
and you go to your room.
And you give them a choice.
But again, different families
have so much different stuff
going on that the sibling
stuff is really tricky.
I find the other really
good trick for sibling
is make sure everybody is
fed and well-slept, which
is like a good life thing.
Our worst sibling fights are
in the afternoon when they're
tired and they're worn out.
And then I just have to
like work really hard
to get them set up
in some activity
that involves relatively
little interaction,
because they can't handle it.
Other questions?
Thoughts?
Yeah.
Jessie.
AUDIENCE: So thinking
about being mindful
and how I would do
that in my life.
I worry that time pressure
is the enemy of mindfulness,
and that a lot of times
the intense moments all
have a time pressure aspect.
Like, I need to get
this done by this time,
or get over to this place.
And taking a step back and
slowing down feels very hard.
CARLA NAUMBURG: Yes.
I agree.
And I think we can
all relate to you.
And certainly you can
move fast and be mindful.
There's no question.
Mindfulness does not
require us to be slow,
but it's just easier.
Right?
And so what I would argue
is that there are always
going to be days and moments
when you just feel like you're
moving at 100 miles an hour.
I think the trick is
to convince yourself
that you don't actually have
to move at 100 miles an hour.
And you'll be more
effective if you don't.
And my best example
is I'll get really
stressed when I'm trying to get
out the door in the morning.
And I'm trying to make
the lunches or whatever.
Although, in all fairness, Josh
make lunches most mornings.
I have to give him that.
But when I'm trying to
get everything together
and what inevitably happens
is I drop the blueberries
all over the floor.
Or I've have got
everyone in the car.
And I realize that I've
forgotten something.
And we have to go back.
And so when we can start to
convince ourselves that when
we can practice a little
bit of mindfulness,
it'll actually make things
go faster and more smoothly.
And when I say a little
bit, I mean, literally.
Can you stop and stand and
take three deep breaths.
And then ask yourself,
what do I need to do now?
Or if you're staring down
the barrel of an insane
day with a ton of meetings
and all these projects,
can you stop and take
some deep breaths.
And if you're a person who
likes to write things down,
can you sort of make yourself
a quick list and say,
what are the things
I need to focus on?
Because when our
brains get going,
it's that forward
thinking, we get so
wrapped up in
everything that has
to happen in the future, and
all the worries about what
if I don't get this done,
that we end up just reacting.
Like, oh, now this thing
popped in my brain,
so I'm going to do this.
And then this thing
popped in my brain.
So I'm going to do this.
And that may not be
the most skillful way
to approach the day.
It may be better to take
a few-- it could literally
be five minutes, which I would
argue that since most of us
aren't the President
of the United States,
we actually have five minutes.
We can sit down
and say, what are
the things I need to do today?
What are the most effective
ways to plan my day?
And then when stuff pops up, we
have this map in our mind of,
OK.
But this is what I
was going to do today.
And is that thing
that just popped up,
is that worthy of intruding
on this space and time?
And it's the same
thing with parenting.
If I can go into the
afternoon with a plan,
I'm gonna give my girls a snack.
And then we're going
to have some play time.
And then I'm gonna make dinner.
And then something pops up, I
can sort of make this choice.
Is this the most skillful place
to put my attention right now?
And sometimes it is.
Sometimes we just have to
react, especially in parenting.
Like, when your kid's about
to fall down the stairs,
you've got to drop whatever
you're doing, go grab them.
But more often than
not, I would argue
we react when we don't need to.
So I think small amounts
of time on a busy day
can make you actually be more
effective during the day.
This book is on Amazon
and local bookstores.
And then "Parenting
in the Present Moment"
is my first book,
which is really
meant more for parents who
want to practice mindfulness.
And I just really
appreciate you all coming.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]